cs2s anti-che isn't only bad at catching
cheaters it might actually be working
backwards Banning hundreds of innocent
people since launch there have been
multiple instances of false band waves
that have affected admins content
creators and even professional players
so I sat down with a group who's had one
Mission getting valve to finally listen
and actually fix their
[Music]
mistakes CS2 has a legit cheating
problem but if you've been following the
subreddit since the game launched you
might have noticed some posts of people
claiming to have been falsely banned now
I personally scrolled past most of these
because false Bannings happened all the
time in CS:GO plus I'm a naive person
who believes in truth and Justice so I
just thought that these things would
eventually sort themselves out on top of
that there was this whole debacle with
those AMD anti- likee plus drivers
accidentally triggering bands which
valve eventually reversed so I assumed
that worst case it was all just more CS2
Growing Pains but even after all of of
that there were still plenty of players
coming out claiming to have been falsely
banned and just as my interest was peing
my colleague was contacted by someone
named coach representing a group of
people investigating this very issue
claiming it was worse than we had even
thought the group is called anti-che PD
a collective of volunteers looking to
expose cheats and disrupt vendors but
since September they started collecting
data on the supposed false bands and
launched an investigation to try and
help these players that seemingly had no
voice at the time so I spoke to members
of the acpd the owner of vcoin and
several others in a call to try and get
to the bottom of why this was happening
now for the sake of protecting some
other ongoing investigations many of
those on the call wanted to remain
anonymous that said they were more than
willing to provide data and insight into
what was going on starting with what
these people were allegedly getting
banned for the acpd listed several
reasons they were getting so many
reports of false bans the majority of
which were as trivial as that false band
wave we saw with the AMD drivers firstly
they were were getting reports of
individuals being banned for having
launch options like allow thirdparty
software certain in-game console
commands using Logitech ghub or project
lasso or sometimes even when using face
it since it required launching in
untrusted mode Hell there were
reportedly even instances of people
getting falsely banned for Force
quitting the client or repeatedly
disconnecting due to network issues next
to all those reasons the acpd were
getting a lot of reports of false bands
over something even more ridiculous High
DPI
oh hey there we go that's it that's how
you get wrongfully banned for cheating I
would highly recommend not trying it but
apparently if you set your DPI super
high and jerk your mouse around you can
potentially get a ban as ridiculous as
that sounds there's a steam group of
nearly 600 users who claim to have been
banned over this some even wanting to
seek legal action hell multiple people
have tested it out to see if they can
recreate it with one user even doing a
speedrun to find out how fast they can
do do it 9 minutes and 9 seconds for
those wondering so the question is why
is it happening well while we don't know
for sure acpd laser and the owner of the
Twitter account vcoin Lea did have a
hypothesis over the last few years valve
has been putting a lot of time and money
into Ai and machine learning for their
antiche we also know that back in March
valve indefinitely removed OverWatch
counter- strike's peer review system for
sussing out cheaters given those two
facts leaw laser and plenty of other
people are under the assumption that
OverWatch has been replaced by AI that
was taught by the very system it was
replacing and as we all know AI can be
pretty scuffed so the assumption is that
this new system is mistaking people
trolling with high DPI as them having
aim Lo obviously a real human would know
the person is Jing around but AI can't
make that distinction but if this is
true and people are getting falsely
banned for this how long is the road
ahead to an actually working antiche I
can't say for sure but I'm not too
hopeful given the final reason so many
people were contacting the AC CPD over
apparent false bands cases of Simply
Mass reporting and one of those such
cases was Bulgarian Counter-Strike
content creator go I think the problem
with me was I got red thr Factor around
three weeks before the ban so I couldn't
find it enemy in Premier and competitive
more than 40 minutes and even if I get a
game I was it was always with cheaters
so my theory is that I played some
competitive games with my friends the
level there is very low so I could
easily make 30 to 40 frags every map and
I think it Go Mass reported there the
stories were all pretty similar get red
trust factor for whatever stupid reason
continue playing and getting Mass
reported every single game you're in and
eventually you might get banned and to
many of these people it was a lot more
than just simply not being able to play
Counterstrike Brazilian Pro hopeful
Vines claimed he was given a false ban
and if that remained unresolved his
career would be at stake the same went
for a face at admin and a few content
creators including goo who for a time
were completely lost Counter-Strike is
his livelihood he's played his entire
life even for the Bulgarian national
team back in 1.6 but for 3 weeks his
life was on hold with no response from
Val yeah it's actually ruined my
reputation because uh many people don't
know what's happening and they're asking
me every day and I can't answer anything
because I'm just waiting for a respon
from Val if I start to play with another
account it will look like I'm smurfing
or griefing they can ban me for this
also so I don't really know what to do
in this situation and I'm starting to
lose hope because nobody's responding Co
even claimed that he had players all the
way in China reaching out to them trying
to get help with their false banss
expressing even more distress because
cheating and selling cheats in that
country can have real world consequences
and with more people reporting false
banss every single day things were only
getting more complicated you see this
false band wave coincided with the very
real bandwave back in September when
users were getting the hammer for
boosting red service medals but it
became impossible to know who was
telling the truth and who wasn't sure
you want to believe everyone who says
they're Innocent but there was no real
way of actually knowing and after all
this the game was still filled with
actual full rage cheaters who themselves
were even commenting on this false ban
issue in complete disbelief and this
went on for at least 3 weeks with no
response from valve despite commenting
on and resolving that AMD issue there's
been nothing said about any of these new
reports of potential false bans I myself
reached out and to this day still
nothing a mod on the Cs subreddit did
give a response last month but as the
acpd explained there's no real way of
verifying if this person actually worked
for valve the acpd also claimed that any
post to the subreddit that included the
words false and banned were immediately
removed and if all of that wasn't bad
enough last week things hit a whole new
level on December 5th many people
including Pros my entire five stack and
I'm sure many of you watching woke up to
bans on their accounts for unknown
reasons with millions in skins locked
away and an unprecedented amount of
people affected alarm Bell started
ringing for a massive false bandwave but
before we could even truly get to the
bottom of what caused this this incident
valve tweeted out that it was an error
that occurred during the game update and
that a roll back on the bands would come
shortly although very bizarre it was
good how quickly valve fixed things
however it only helped people that were
banned on December 5th go Vines and
everyone else that was banned previously
were still and after reaching out to the
group investigating it I couldn't help
but feel slighted on their behalf Pros
big names in the community millions of
dollars worth in skins that was
obviously going to get a reaction from
valve but the people previously affected
for almost a month now it felt like they
weren't worth the effort thankfully my
assessment of the situation ended up
being a little bit too harsh because on
the 6th we finally got something Vin
Beast our pal gico and plenty of other
people who seemingly were banned because
of a red trust Factor have now been
rolled back albe it with still no
comment from valve my guess is that all
of the attention received from the
December 5th Wave got valve to finally
do something about these other poor
souls and I don't think it would have
been possible without the efforts from
the acpd bcoin and everyone else
involved unfortunately this is just a
small victory because as of recording it
seems like almost if not all of the high
DPI Bans are still in place and we don't
even know if valve has the capabilities
of resolving this one unless they just
unban everyone including cheaters my
only guess is that they would have to go
back and manually review every single
demo file which brings us to the larger
issue of all of this happening in the
first place and valve not being
transparent about it and the reality is
that for every person that gets falsely
banned the path to an actual working
anti-che gets a lot longer I don't think
we're going to wake up one day with a
working system listen Val's lack of
communication used to be a meme and it
still is but every day it gets less and
less funny the game being a bit
unpolished with a lack of content on
launch I urged people to be patient
cheaters roaming matchmaking without the
fear of facing any consequences well now
we have an issue but innocent players
being banned for seemingly no reason boy
what are we doing here it was
interesting all the people I talk to at
the acpd in bcoin it's funny because
like their whole thing is supposed to be
like finding like the biggest cheat
Sellers and trying to like disrupt them
but it's like now their job has like
seemingly turned into like being defense
Council for like these people that have
been apparently false banned so shout
out to them